would you recommend that newlyweds
should watch your documentary romione
this is a payment yes or no mmm is it
good question very I think I'll just
tell you my experience the last couple
years and last night when i was outside
the theater when we first screened the
movie in san diego was like standing
room only it was very as an honor and i
had people come up to me and there was a
couple they'd said hey you know we're
actually we're going to were getting
ready to go through the divorce process
and after your film we've decided to go
to a mediator and not go to attorneys
and and you know that was like oh cool
there was a message there and last night
there was a guy he kept walking by and
he saw the poster and he goes I gotta
see that film he's telling his
girlfriend and I came around the corner
and I was handing out postcards for
people to come and watch him and he goes
hey your Romeo I got ya yeah for me oh
because I had no I was just telling her
I was going I go yeah I think I heard
you and I go you guys married ago no
we're just good friends we each have a
child and we I was looking at that movie
and I wanted to go see it and we were
just talking and they're like you know
we had a conversation about you know she
had an ex he had an ex but they were
coming together they were debating of
getting married because of all of the
you know we live in a different society
today you know there's a lot of negative
stuff going on and so we had this
dialogue and they're like do you think
you know it didn't come up like do you
think we could do it but I said why
don't you watch the film and he goes I
was going to watch it and I think we're
going to have a great conversation over
it and so yes I think people should
really take 66 minutes out of their day
and watch it
you